hey guys
you know I'm on my way to the gym and I
realized that I haven't been to the gym
in almost a month
that's just how busy we are here at dlm
my team and I are working crazy early
mornings late nights and trying to get
videos out there to share the gospel on
men's lifestyle and Christian lifestyle
every week and it's been difficult
we have load shedding here in South
Africa scheduled power outages which
makes things worse
and uh thank you Liz and Ross from our
dlm family for buying for us and a
generator for me and for Donny and jock
the the team manager and the head video
editor they bought them inverters which
is amazing so the three of us can power
through power outages
but I want to ask you guys to please
continue to pray for us and support us
as a team
I love you guys and thank you